Professor Mark Saltzman:
So, what I'm going to talk
about today and Thursday is two
topics,
which what I hope to do is sort
of bring together some of the
information that we've been
talking about over the course of
the term.
To do that, I want to focus on
two areas, today talk about
cancer--a big subject,
and so we'll just scratch the
surface.
The main point that I want to
make is how some of the
technologies that we've been
talking about over the course of
the term are having an impact on
cancer diagnosis and care,
and to sort of point to some
areas where they'll likely be
more progress and opportunities
for progress in the future.
Then, on Thursday,
we'll do the same thing but
talking about the subject of
artificial organs.
One that we've brushed on a
couple of times through the
semester, but just try to spend
some focus time on it on
Thursday.
Section meeting on Thursday
afternoon, we'll do a course
review.
I'll be there for each of the
sections.
I'll just be leading a
discussion about what we've
covered in the course and what
kinds of things will be on the
final.
Any questions?
You know what's described
here on this slide,
that cancer is a deadly and,
unfortunately,
not uncommon disease.
These are some statistics from
2006 collected by The American
Cancer Society.
One of the things that we do
fairly well as a nation,
now, is keep track of cancer
cases and progress.
This has been an important part
of our learning about where
cancers occur,
what are the causes and what
treatments work and what don't.
The American Cancer Society has
been a big part of that effort
to collect information on where
cancers occur in the country,
in what people,
in what age groups,
and to provide that information
for people that are working on
research for cancer.
This just summarizes some
of that information.
For 2006, new cases of cancer
you can see over a million new
cases, deaths from cancer about
half a million and roughly equal
between males and females.
Here's some common types of
cancer occurring in females,
breast cancer in both males and
females, lung cancer,
and in males only prostate
cancer.
The statistics are alarming.
You look at the number of
deaths that are caused by cancer
and if you want to learn more
about sort of that,
I urge you to go to The
American Cancer Society website
which is listed here.
Just a few facts about
cancer that you probably know
something about this,
it's now the most common cause
of death in the U.S.
and that's true in many
developed countries.
Cancer and heart disease have
been neck and neck in terms of
the number one cause of deaths
in developed countries for many
years now.
It looks like cancer is winning
and we'll talk about that in a
minute.
Cancer's caused by mutations in
genes that control cell growth.
You know that a cancer or
formation of a tumor is an
unwanted or uncontrolled growth
of cells.
Cell division runs amuck and
cells don't stop dividing under
circumstances where they're
supposed to.
So, you get--a mass is formed
and that mass is--it represents
the unwanted growth of cells.
The mutations that cause
cancer, that cause these defects
in cell growth,
can be either inherited or
environmental.
We know that there are thing in
the environment that cause
cancer, some viruses can cause
cancers.
One of the clearest links is
between human papillomavirus,
a sexually transmitted disease
and cervical cancer in women.
There is a new vaccine for HPV,
human papillomavirus and it's
expected that this vaccine which
will prevent spread of the virus
will also significantly reduce
cancer cases.
Other kinds of viruses are
linked to liver cancers,
for example.
Chemicals can also,
in the environment,
can also cause cancer,
and we'll talk more about that
in a minute.
Most cancers also involve some
genetic changes that can be
either acquired or inherited.
You know also that cancer can
run in families.
The risk of certain kinds of
cancers, there's a genetic basis
for that.
In the U.S.,
the lifetime risk of cancer is
1 in 2 for men.
So, half of men will have some
kind of cancer,
and 1 in 3 for women.
That's a pretty impressive
number.
The age adjusted mortality rate
for cancer is about the same in
the 21st century as it was 50
years ago,
that is, the rate of death from
cancer hasn't changed very much
in the last 50 years.
This, in spite of the fact that
there's been a lot of attention
to cancer and learning more
about cancer,
and its causes,
the basic biology and in trying
to design new methods for
diagnosing and treating cancer.
But overall deaths haven't
changed very much;
we've made progress in certain
kinds of tumors but not in
others.
This just, I think,
reflects the fact that both
cancer is a heterogeneous
disease.
You know that it occurs in a
variety of sites throughout the
body, but in each of those sites
cancers can be quite different.
It's not one disease but its
family of diseases.
Because of that,
it's been hard to make progress
in treatment because all of them
have slightly different
characteristics.
This just illustrates that
last point a little more
clearly.
Change in U.S.
death rates by cause from 1950
to 2003, so over that period
deaths from heart disease went
down dramatically.
Deaths from cerebral vascular
diseases, so deaths of the
circulatory system in the brain,
so this is mainly stroke and
aneurisms down dramatically.
Deaths from infectious
diseases, we talked about
vaccines several weeks ago which
has a big impact on mortality
from infectious diseases,
also down over that years.
Deaths from cancer stay about
the same.
While we've made great
progress, we're not yet at the
point where we're changing the
outcomes from cancer very
dramatically.
I mentioned a few minutes
ago that exposure to chemicals
can cause cancer,
and you know this.
One of the most well known
exposures that's clearly a cause
of cancer is tobacco use.
This is tobacco use mainly
thinking about cigarette
smoking, but the same thing
could be true of any kind of
tobacco use.
Smoking in other--cigars or
chewing tobacco also causes
cancer because the chemicals in
cigarette smoke or in tobacco,
in particular.
Some of the tars that are
associated with smoking cause
cancer of the lung in
particular.
This was first noticed by
looking at epidemiological data.
We talked about public health
and epidemiology a few weeks ago
where you look at how diseases
appear in populations and you
try to figure out why things are
changing.
Here's as cigarettes were
consumed more in the U.S.,
you can see the trend in
cigarette consumption going up
over time from 1900 to 1950.
Then, lagging behind that by
about a period of 30 years,
is a dramatic increase in lung
cancer.
First among men and then among
women, and the reason for that
is because cigarette smoking was
initially more popular among men
than among women,
but advertising and the women's
movement changed that.
Cigarette smoking became
something that everybody could
do.
It was acceptable in polite
society for women to smoke,
and they were targeted by
manufacturers of cigarettes.
Special cigarettes were made
for women, they're special in
some way but not in their
ability to cause cancer,
they're all the same and so
female lung cancer still rising.
You can see we've made progress
in male lung cancer,
mainly by reducing the number
of smokers, but that hasn't yet
happened in women.
Evidence first came from
epidemiology but then after it
was realized that there was an
association between cigarettes
smoking and cancer.
Then, you can start to look
more closely and try to figure
out what the molecular cause of
it is.
We now know quite a lot
about how the chemicals in smoke
cause these sorts of malignant
transformations in cells that
lead to cancer.
The evidence is pretty clear.
The main point that exposure to
chemicals can cause cancer.
This just to try to put in
perspective where cancer occurs,
what are the most frequent
causes of cancer that lead to
death,
and in both men and women,
lunch cancer is number one.
After that it changes the top
three in men being lung,
colon and prostate;
in women lung,
breast and colon and accounting
for just those top three,
the large majority of cancers.
Cancer of the pancreas is much
less common but because it's so
difficult to detect and we'll
talk about methods of detection.
The pancreas is an organ that's
deep within your body and it's
hard to find when things are
going wrong with it.
Because it's difficult to
detect cancer of the pancreas it
very frequently leads to death,
and of course this is in the
news now because this is the
kind of cancer that Patrick
Swayze has.
Life expectancy when you have
pancreatic cancer is--life
expectancy is very low because
it's usually in an advanced
stage when it's discovered.
Cancer cells are different,
so what makes all these cancers
at different sites similar is
the similar characteristics that
the cells that form cancers
have.
I mentioned already that one of
the things that characterizes
cancer is that cells divide
abnormally.
They divide,
usually, more rapidly.
We talked about,
several weeks ago when we were
talking about cell culture,
we talked about cells that you
would isolate from tissue and
they would grow at a rate of
about by doubling their number
everyday if you maintained them
in culture.
Cancer cells can grow much
faster than that so they have
mechanisms for dividing very
rapidly.
More importantly probably,
they don't stop proliferating
when they're supposed too.
You know, from what we've
talked about before,
that there are cells that are
continually dividing and
reproducing within your body.
Cells in you intestinal tract
for example, cells in the liver,
cells in the kidney continually
dividing, cells in your skin.
But ordinarily your skin stays
the same size that it is because
are cells are dividing but they
know when to stop.
They stop when they reach the
right density,
the right shape,
they know where they're
supposed to be.
Cancer cells don't,
they continue to divide even
when they get signals that
they're supposed to stop
dividing.
Because of this tumors form,
abnormal growths--the organ
of--origin becomes larger than
it ordinarily would.
They generally don't
respond to signals that are
provided by neighboring cells,
we talked about cell
communication and how important
that was for the life of a
tissue.
For your liver to be your liver
and your brain to your brain,
they don't just have the right
cells there but they have cells
that are communicating in the
right way.
There's a loss of that normal
molecular communication when you
have cancer.
They don't differentiate
normally but tend to remain as
immature de-differentiated or
undifferentiated cells.
What's this like?
This is like we talked about
stem cells, stem cells are less
mature than differentiated
tissue cells.
They grow rapidly;
both stem cells which
self-renew and cancer cells.
They don't form mature types of
cells and there's a lot of
linkages know known between stem
cells and cancer.
Some people think that within
any individual tumor,
there are cancer stem cells
that really are the most
important ones to treat.
If you get rid of even the bulk
of cancer cells without getting
rid of these very stem like
cells in cancers the tumors will
regrow again.
So, normal differentiation
like stem cells is a problem
with cancer cells.
They don't adhere readily to
other cells and extracellular
matrix, they do not become
specialized and die.
Because cells in your skin are
continually going through not
just birth, not just growth of
new cells but death.
There's skin cells that are
dying and being shed from your
body all the time.
Cancer cells don't undergo
those normal processes of cell
death that lead to regulation of
tissue structure.
If a cancer forms,
it tends to go through
different stages and that this
cell, for example,
in this tissue is a
pre-malignant cell.
If it becomes malignant,
it will start dividing and
growing out of control and you
can see that here.
That tumor that forms at the
initial site or the site of the
origin of a cancer is called the
primary tumor.
These tumors,
if they grew,
would ordinarily stop at a size
of about one millimeter,
very small.
You wouldn't even be able to
notice them, maybe,
if they're only a millimeter or
so in size.
They don't grow beyond that as
a cell mass because they can't
get nutrients,
oxygen, glucose,
the things that the cell needs,
amino acids.
The things that it needs in
order to produce new cells can't
get in because those are
normally provided by the
bloodstream.
When the cell is just dividing
out of control there's no blood
supply.
Many people think that tumor
size would be limited.
Cancer wouldn't be such a
problem, except for the fact
that cancers at this stage,
as they move from this primary
stage to invasive cancer,
they develop an ability to
stimulate the growth of blood
vessels So,
now you can see blood vessels
are growing into and through
this tumor, they develop their
own blood supply.
They're able to get nutrients
readily, and this is when the
growth of the tumor really
starts to take off.
We'll talk about some therapies
that block this process of new
tumor growth called
angiogenesis.
Many people think if you could
block that process selectively
in tumors then you could halt
all tumors to a very small size
that would not cause problems.
An additional stage after
angiogenesis that some tumors
can go through is a process
called metastasis.
That's where tumor cells
actually leave their site of
origin and travel to other
places in the body.
That's shown schematically in
this cartoon here.
A tumor cell entering the
circulation, it can flow through
the circulation,
and maybe get lodged at some
distant site and begin the
process of tumor formation at
that distant site.
This is obviously a bad thing
because maybe you can treat the
primary tumor in a variety of
different ways which we'll talk
about in just a minute.
Once it begins to spread
throughout the body becomes much
more difficult to treat.
You have not just one tumor,
but potentially hundreds or
thousands of tumors that are
forming throughout the body.
The treatment for
tumors--for cancer--depends very
much on what stage it's at when
it's identified.
For every kind of cancer
physicians, oncologists,
have developed classification
methods for talking about,
to each other,
about what stage the cancer is
at.
I'll just show you that in an
example of that in bladder
cancer.
You might have an initial stage
here which is called TA.
T is the tumor rating,
T for tumor.
This is a very small tumor
that's just confined to the
lining.
When it gets larger it's
classified as T1.
When it gets up to stage T2
it's starting to invade from the
lining of the bladder into the
other tissues of the bladder,
T3, T4.
By the time it's got to stage
T4, it's occupying not only the
whole thickness of the wall of
the bladder but it's started to
invade other tissues like the
prostate as well.
You can see that if you
have a tumor that's at one of
these early stages,
local therapy might work;
surgery or radiation,
or local chemotherapy which
we'll talk about.
As it begins to invade other
organs, then it becomes more
difficult to treat.
They can spread and I don't
mean for you to--tumors can
spread, and I don't mean for you
to be able to see all this here
but you can look at this,
these slides will be posted as
usual.
Not only can you classify the
normal--the original site of the
tumor and that's classifications
of melanoma from T1 up to T4 and
they're defined here,
but you can classify whether it
has spread locally to lymph
nodes.
That's these end stages here,
and whether it has metastasized
to different sites.
Ordinarily, a physician will
classify a tumor according to
the tumor nodal involvement
metastasis classification that's
appropriate for that kind of
tumor.
This allows physicians to
say exactly where your cancer is
at in development.
We know, because we've been
treating cancer for a long time
now, you can select a treatment
that's most likely to work for
the stage that it's at.
This, all to say that
diagnosing specifically where a
cancer is at in its development
within a patient is very
important for deciding what kind
of a treatment is likely to lead
to a good outcome.
One of the things that
biomedical engineers have worked
very diligently on over the last
50 years or so is designing new
methods for cancer diagnosis.
We've talked about some of
these as we've gone through the
course and I just want to
highlight them here.
We talked about X-rays and
using X-ray radiation to look
inside the body.
Mammography is a special kind
of X-ray imaging that's used to
look just at the breasts to see
if there are abnormal tissues
within the breast.
This shows a normal mammogram
and this shows a mammogram with
some kind of a dense deposit
here that's not normal.
Mammography is used to screen
for breast cancer and it's a
very important screen.
Now women, when they reach a
certain age, are recommended to
have mammography a certain
number of times per year or per
decade just to try to detect
cancers at an early stage.
This is an example of
biomedical engineering for
diagnosis.
Pap smears also done during
routine pelvic exams in women,
where a swab is used to remove
some cells from the cervical
region.
Then you can look at these
cells under the microscope and
here's what a normal Pap smear
would look like.
You can see the cells are flat,
they have small nuclei,
not a lot of protein and so the
cells don't stain very darkly.
Malignant cells,
on the other hand,
cells that indicate there might
be cancer present have larger
nuclei, more intense staining,
abnormal shapes.
So, someone who looks at cells
from cervical Pap smears all the
time can quickly tell if there's
the danger that there might be a
tumor growing within a patient
who's had a smear like this.
Now, this requires a visit
to the office and a procedure;
wouldn't it be nice if there
were blood tests that you could
do for cancer?
Of all the technologies we
talked about;
we talked about ELISA's for
example and all the ways that we
can look into the blood to try
to see what chemicals are
present there.
If you could find chemical
signatures of cancer that could
be detected in blood,
or in urine,
or in some other fluid from the
body, that would be a great
thing.
Unfortunately,
there aren't too many examples
of that yet.
We don't know how to do that
very well.
We do know for prostate cancer
and for certain other kinds of
cancers there are molecules that
you can detect in the blood.
In prostate cancer there's a
very particular molecule called
prostate specific antigen,
PSA.
If the levels of PSA rise in
your blood, that's a sign that
there's something going wrong in
your prostate and you get a more
thorough exam.
Blood tests are available but
only for certain kinds of
cancers and they're not widely
available yet,
although we would like for them
to be.
If you have a high--if
you're a male and you have an
abnormally high prostate
specific antigen level in your
blood,
you might get a more thorough
examination and you might
use--and your physician might
use an approach like ultrasound
guided biopsy.
Here, if you can see in this
diagram here,
this is a much less pleasant
experience then a blood test but
there's a device that's inserted
through the rectum up to close
to where the prostate is.
This device has an ultrasound
probe on it.
You can look by ultrasound into
this region of the body,
identify where the prostate is,
and even where a growth on the
prostate might be and then a
needle comes out from this
device and takes a small sample
of tissue.
This tissue is then taken to
the laboratory and looked at in
the same way that a Pap smear
might be looked at.
We talked about using
optical microscopy or using
optical instruments to probe
inside the body into cavities
that we can't see.
There's lots of technology
available for this now,
including sigmoidoscopes and
colonoscopes,
which are fiber optic systems
that can be inserted into the
colon.
Can be--if they're designed
properly, inserted very far up
into the colon to actually let
you look through a lens at
what's happening on the surface
of the tissue.
This has been a very important
advance in terms of identifying
cancer of the colon,
for example.
Similar scopes are available to
look in the lung for lung cancer
and to look in a variety of
other sites in the body to look
for cancer and other diseases.
A lot of engineering technology
has been brought to bear on the
problem of diagnosing cancer and
diagnosing cancer early.
What do you do if a cancer
is present?
Well the--arguably the oldest
form of cancer therapy is
surgery.
Surgery is used for biopsy to
take small samples to see if a
growth, for example,
is abnormal.
If you have an abnormal growth
on your skin,
the surgeon might cut off some
of that tissue and send it to a
laboratory for analysis and to
find out if it's cancer or not.
Also used for looking deeper in
the body, surgery is.
Surgery is used for prevention
of cancer.
If you have abnormal growths
called polyps in the colon,
a surgeon can remove those
polyps and prevent them from
progressing into a more serious
disease.
Polyps on their own aren't
necessarily cancerous but they
can develop into cancer,
there's an association with
that.
So, why not remove them
surgically before they have the
chance?
Surgeries often remove--used to
remove local tumors in the lung,
in the brain,
the colon, the prostate,
so surgery is a well
established form of cancer
treatment.
Radiation can also be used
to treat cancer.
This relates to the subject of
imaging that we talked about
several weeks ago.
We talked about using
electromagnetic radiation
because it can penetrate into
the body and using that to take
pictures of what's inside.
But we also talked about forms
of radiation that had biological
effects.
We talked about ionizing
radiation, for example,
and ionizing radiation can
cause changes in the body.
This is radiation that's on the
high frequency,
short wavelength end of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
So, X-rays or gamma rays,
high frequency,
small wavelength.
They can penetrate through
tissues very easily and they can
interact with atoms and nuclei
inside of the molecules inside
your body.
Ionizing radiation,
these forms of high energy
radiation have biological
effects.
We talked about one of those
effects is that they can cause
the ejection or the deviation of
electrons on atoms within the
skin.
These change,
these ionizations that occur as
a electrons are ejected from
atoms within the skin,
can cause cell damage.
This kind of ionization is
happening all the time.
You go out in the sun and
radiation impinges on your skin,
it causes some damage.
There are forms of ionizing
radiation present at low levels
in the environment around us,.
Ordinarily that causes no
problem because the cells in
your body are able to repair
damage.
You have repair mechanisms,
either by producing new cells
or by repairing the DNA that
gets damaged in cells,
you can recover from the damage
that happens.
But if radiation continues to
be delivered to that tissue,
you can overwhelm the body's
ability to repair itself.
You can actually cause sections
of tissues or cells within
sections of tissues to die,
and that's the basis for
radiation therapy.
This graph which is--which
describes an experiment that was
done many decades ago,
shows how radiation can be used
to kill cells.
This axis here shows a dose of
radiation that's delivered to
cells in culture.
Radiation is focused on a Petri
dish that contains cells and
then you expose them to some
amount of radiation.
The dose of radiation is going
up as you move this way.
Then, you look to see how many
cells survived that procedure,
how many cells survived this
dose of radiation.
Let's look at a dose of 6 Gy
here, Gy is a radiation unit
called the Gray.
At this dose of Gy's,
if you move up this scale here,
you'll kill all but .001
fraction or .1% of bone marrow
cells.
You would kill most of the bone
marrow cells that were exposed
by radiation of this kind.
You would kill about 90% of
cells from the breast,
and you would kill even less of
these other kinds of cells here.
That illustrates another
point, that cells have different
sensitivities to radiation.
If you know something about the
type of cells you're trying to
treat by radiation,
then you can adjust the dose
that you give so you're killing
only the ones that you want.
Some cells are always going to
be susceptible.
Cells of the bone marrow,
for example,
very susceptible to radiation.
How do you avoid that problem?
That you want to kill cells of
the tumor but you don't want to
kill cells that are also
sensitive to radiation in other
parts of the body?
You do that by just focusing
the radiation on the site that
you want.
You do it by localizing where
the radiation is delivered.
So, biomedical engineers
and physicists have developed
methods for external beam
radiation.
These are devices that look
somewhat like the imaging
systems we talked about several
weeks ago.
They're delivering high doses
of ionizing radiation and you
can see that perhaps that this
thing is on a cradle that swings
back and forth,
and there are lenses in here to
focus the radiation.
The physician can move it to
whatever site that he wants in
three dimensions and focus the
beam so it hits only the tissue
that you want to expose to
radiation.
These techniques depend very
much on computers and on
mathematical models of what the
tissue looks like inside your
body,
they're guided by imaging
methods, but the idea is to
deliver only radiation at the
site that you want too.
Can you do a perfect job?
No, but you can do a pretty
good job in focusing the
radiation at the site that you
want.
This is described a little bit
more in the chapter in your
book.
Another way to get
radiation delivered only where
you want is to put the radiation
source inside the body in the
location you want and that's
called Brachytherapy.
This is an example of a
prostate tumor that's filled
with what looked like little
stars, or little bright dots.
Each one of these bright dots
is a small metal seed that's
filled with a radioactive
material.
Those are implanted physically
in the tissue,
and then the tissue around it
is exposed to radiation.
It's a special kind of
radiation that only penetrates a
certain depth in the tissue.
As it penetrates,
it delivers ionizing radiation
to all the cells around it.
You can see these small seeds
are arrayed throughout the
tissue so that you can treat it
as uniformally as possible.
So, radiation can be used to
treat tumors.
Another thing I wanted to
show you on this slide here is
that some cells can be made to
be more sensitive to radiation
and they ordinarily are.
That example is shown here with
these human cells that have
been--well, that they lack the
normal DNA repair mechanisms.
Cells that lack DNA repair
mechanisms, if you expose them
to ionizing radiation;
they're much more sensitive
because they don't have the
mechanisms to repair sub-lethal
damage.
One important area of research
is trying to find drugs that you
can deliver that will accumulate
in tumor tissue to make them
more sensitive to radiation,
which you then deliver in the
ways that I've described.
There are a variety of
different approaches that are
under study here for delivering
radiation more carefully,
more selectively,
to specific regions of the
body, and to design drugs or
other strategies to make tumors
more sensitive to the radiation
you deliver.
You know about chemotherapy.
Again, this is a slide that I
don't intend for you to be able
to read on your--in your
leisure,
you can look at the slide when
it's posted and just gives you
some idea of the breadth of
knowledge that we now have about
chemotherapy drugs.
There are many different
classes of drugs that have been
developed and studied and
employed for treating cancer.
Most of these drugs work in a
similar fashion,
by interfering with DNA,
or by interfering with the
mechanisms by which cells repair
DNA so that you can halt cell
growth.
If you crosslink all the DNA
inside of a cell it can't
synthesize any more DNA.
Then, it can't divide and
proliferate and that's the basis
of action for many of these,
although not all,
so I'll let you look at those
at your leisure.
One of the problems with
chemotherapy is that these drugs
have effect not only on tumor
cells but they have effects on
normal cells.
If you deliver chemotherapy
throughout the body,
not only do you have an effect
on the tumor,
an effect that you want,
but you have an effect on other
tissues.
In particular,
the kinds of tissues where cell
growth, controlled cell growth
is an important part of their
physiology;
the intestine,
the bone marrow,
your hair, skin.
Patients who have chemotherapy
often get digestive problems,
severe digestive problems.
T hey get anemia,
or infections because they're
not producing cells in their
bone marrow anymore.
They lose their hair because
hair is produced by cells that
are dividing,
in the skin.
They get rashes and other skin
symptoms because their skin
isn't repairing and remodeling
in the normal way,
you know this.
One concept that has
emerged over the last 10 years
or so is to deliver chemotherapy
drugs locally instead of
delivering them over the whole
body.
I gave you this example from my
own research lab a few weeks ago
when we were talking about drug
delivery.
Just to remind you,
here's a situation where
there's a tumor in the brain.
This can be treated by surgery,
and in this case the surgeons
were given drug delivery
systems.
These were degradable polymer
wafers that were filled with
high concentrations of
chemotherapy.
In the operating room,
after they removed the tumor,
they can place these drug
delivery systems in the brain.
The patient leaves the
operating room with most of the
tumor removed,
and with high dose chemotherapy
delivered locally over a long
period of time after they leave
the operating room.
This should remind you of the
Brachytherapy we talked about a
few slides ago.
Instead of depositing a dose of
radiation in here,
we deposited a dose of drugs.
Deposited it in a way that
these drugs could be released
slowly over time,
and hopefully locally kill any
residual tumor cells that are
remaining.
One of the most impressive,
important and exciting new
developments over the last 5
years has been the development
of new chemotherapy agents that
work by mechanisms of action
that were not known previously.
This is an example of modern
biology and our understanding of
cancer biology,
in particular,
leading to the design of drugs
that are more specific to
cancers,
because they take advantage of
mechanisms that only cancer
cells typically use.
One of those is a drug called
Gleevec.
Remember in the 4^(th) week of
the class we talked about cell
communication.
We talked about signal
transduction and how messages
get from the outside of a cell
into the inside of a cell.
We talked about how important a
class of signaling molecules
called tyrosine kinases were to
creating intracellular signals.
Well, it turns out that
certain kinds of tumors you use
a special tyrosine kinase called
BCRABL and that that tyrosine
kinase can be inhibited by a
drug that was designed to
inhibit it,
called Gleevec.
Now, this is one of the first
examples of what's called
rational drug design,
in that biologists have
identified this particular
tyrosine kinase.
They knew it was involved in
signaling inside certain kinds
of cancers, in particular,
a certain kind of lymphoma.
They studied this molecule in
its molecular detail and
developed a drug,
now called Gleevec,
that would interfere with the
action of that molecule.
Interfere only with the action
of that molecule and not all the
other tyrosine kinases that are
important for healthy cell life
in the rest of your body.
This drug prevents kinase
activity;
it does it by blocking the
binding site for ATP.
Remember that ATP was a second
messenger that kinases use in
order to phosphorylate protein.
This is an exciting example
because it's the first--one of
the first examples of rational
design of a drug at a very
specific molecular target inside
tumors.
Now, unfortunately,
it's limited.
Gleevec is limited in its use
to only a couple of subclasses
of tumors that express this
tyrosine kinase at high
concentrations,
but I think the idea of it is
one that can be translated
outside.
Another new drug that's
been developed in the last two
years is called Herceptin.
Now, Herceptin is unique in a
number of different ways.
One is that it's an antibody,
and we talked about the role of
antibodies in the immune
response several weeks ago.
We talked about how vaccines
are often designed in order to
get your body to produce
antibodies to an infectious
disease.
So, you're familiar with the
concept of using antibodies to
neutralize pathogens.
Here's an antibody that was
designed to bind to a receptor
that appears only on cells in
breast cancer.
This receptor is called HER2;
it's a form of a growth factor
receptor that is particularly
highly expressed in some kinds
of breast cancers.
If you deliver this
molecule Herceptin,
it's an antibody which binds to
this receptor and prevents its
normal function.
Its normal function is to
signal breast cancer cells to
grow.
When this antibody binds,
it shuts off that growth signal
that the breast tumor cell is
getting from this receptor.
It also promotes the immune
response to the tumor.
You can imagine if this is a
breast cancer cell that has lots
of these receptor molecules on
the surface and now you put in
an antibody,
you deliver an antibody which
gets coated on the surface,
now this surface is
tagged--this cell is tagged for
recognition by your immune
system.
The immune system can develop a
response to this tumor as well.
These are both exciting new
potential therapies for cancer.
They're real therapies for some
cancer, but point the way
towards more broadly applicable
methods that might be used to
designing chemotherapy agents.
The problem is that it takes a
long time and a lot of money,
and a lot of effort in order to
get from the point where you
design a new chemotherapy drug
to the point where it can be
used in patients.
I thought I would end this
lecture by just reviewing a
little bit about that process
and try to get you a sense for
why,
in practical terms,
there haven't been more drugs
developed for cancer over the
past several decades.
The process occurs in steps
and I'm going to look at it over
a time scale of about 20 years
here.
It involves both testing in
vitro, testing in test tubes
in the laboratory.
Testing, often in cell
cultures, to look for drugs that
have properties that you think
might make them useful cancer.
Usually from the time that you
think about a drug,
I have a drug,
say drug X and I think it might
inhibit this signaling pathway
in colon cancer.
So, what do I do first?
I get some colon cancer cells,
I expose it to the drug,
I see if it works in culture.
This is all called the
discovery phase.
The next stage I might do if I
find that my drug works well in
cultured cells and I'm starting
to uncover the molecular
mechanisms and how it works,
is test it in animals.
I might take animals that have
colon cancer and try to treat
them with a drug.
This is still in discovery and
this is a phase that--called
animal testing.
Now, you begin to refine
your approach.
You begin to refine your
approach such that you're
starting to test not only for
the activity in animals because
you find that,
'Yes, your drug X does--is an
effective treatment for cancer.'
You trying to think about
what's the optimal dose,
how much dose would I need if
this worked the same way in
people.
You start testing different
aspects of it in animals in
preparation for testing in
people.
That's called,
that first step in vitro
is called lead discovery.
My lead drug is X,
this is a promising lead that
I'm following,
and in animal testing you do
lead optimization.
All of this takes a long time,
could take 4 years from the
point that you think,
'Maybe this drug is good,' to,
'Yes I've shown that really is
effective in animals.'
Then, a process of clinical
testing happens,
and the clinical testing occurs
in phases.
In order to do testing
clinically, you have to be
approved by the government to do
that.
In this country an organization
called the Food and Drug
Administration,
the FDA,
is the only one that can give
you approval to take--to test an
experimental medicine in people.
They do that because you file
an application called an IND or
Investigational New Drug
application.
They look at all the data
you've collected over the last
four years and they say,
'Yes you've convinced us that
this looks like a good drug,
it looks like it'll be safe,
you can go ahead and start
testing it in people.'
You first do small studies,
you deliver to a few people,
usually not people that have
disease, but people that don't
have disease.
You deliver it in small doses
and you slowly increase the
amount of dose that you give
them.
What you're looking for here is
not effectiveness of the drug
but you're looking for safety.
Is it safe?
What dose do I begin to see
side effects?
This allows you to narrow in
the range that you're going to
use in people to test this drug
for its effectiveness,
that's called Phase I.
Phase II, you start to look in
patients that have the disease
in a small number of patients,
to just look to see if the drug
is effective or not.
Phase I, you're asking whether
it's safe, in Phase II you're
asking if it's effective in the
patients that you would like to
use it in.
You do that in a small number
of patients first just because
this is the first time it's been
used to test effectiveness in
people and you're not quite sure
what's going to happen.
So, you do it in a small number
of patients just to show that it
works the way that you want.
If it does work the way you
want you start Phase III which
is a very large clinical study
that is in the number of
patients you need to show that
it is effective at treating the
kind of cancer you want.
How many patients are involved
in studies like this?
Well, it could be hundreds,
could be thousands.
Depends on the disease,
how prevalent the disease is,
what the normal course of the
disease is,
and how many patients you need
to look at in order to be
absolutely sure that you saw an
effect that wasn't just due to
chance.
These are very complicated
studies to do,
and hence very expensive.
Remember when we were
talking about vaccines,
we talked about a Phase III
study of the polio vaccine that
was invented by Jonas Salk.
How many patients were involved
in that clinical study,
does anybody remember?
How many patients were involved
in that Phase III clinical study
of the polio vaccine?
Who could remember that?
I remember;
1.8 million eight year olds
were involved in that study,
so clinical studies can be
huge.
In the case of an infectious
disease, it's particularly a
large number because you need to
deliver it to enough people to
see--a vaccine,
to see that you've changed the
incidence of disease within a
population.
In cancer trials,
they tend to be hundreds or
thousands in size.
If this Phase III trial
works then you're allowed to
sell the drug.
The FDA gives you permission to
sell the drug,
and for physicians to prescribe
it.
The study doesn't end there,
in that all manufacturers of
drugs are required to keep track
of what happens as their drug is
introduced into the population.
This is called Phase IV,
as physicians start using it to
treat cancer they're required to
look at how these things work.
You will have noticed,
in the newspaper over the past
few years, some very famous
drugs that turned out to have
side effects that weren't
expected after they were
released into the general
population.
Once it starts being used by
physicians all over the country
in many, many more patients
sometimes rare side effects
appear that we didn't expect
before.
So, one continues to do
research and study even after
that.
The challenge for drug
companies is that this takes a
very long time,
it takes a lot of money.
There's lots of places where
your drug can fail.
My drug X, which I described as
going neatly through in
vitro studies,
animal testing,
clinical testing might have
stopped working at some stage.
I might have found some problem
with its safety when I started
testing it in human volunteers.
I might have found that it
didn't work as well in animals
as I expected it too based on
in vitro studies.
People estimate that for every
10,000 compounds,
10,000 X's that are thought of
in laboratories,
only one of them eventually
gets approved by the FDA.
This is why drug development
costs so much money in this
country, because you have to
look at a lot of compounds and
test them pretty extensively to
find the one that's really
useful for treating disease.
I don't think we want to
change that, because this
process of FDA approval was
introduced early in this century
when people were selling drugs
out of the back of covered
wagons and moving from town to
town.
They're called snake oil
salesmen or other things.
People could sell anything they
wanted and claimed that it
treated a disease.
Now, we have a very highly
refined system for asking people
that are going to sell drugs to
prove that they work,
but that system costs a lot of
money.
There are opportunities,
I think, for biomedical
engineers to improve how this
works by designing better
methods for in vitro
study.
By using techniques we talked
about, like in cell culture
early on, to use those
techniques more efficiently,
to discover and test properties
of drugs.
So, this is going to be an area
where I think there is lots of
growth and opportunities in the
future.
Just in closing,
I just put this website up
there;
it's from Science Magazine
which is a very high-profile
scientific journal.
They published a poster which
is available online that talks
about sort of modern
developments in cancer diagnosis
and treatment.
I put a few sort of snapshots
from that poster into the Power
Point presentation which will be
available.
I encourage you to go to this
website and look at this
information.
You can find out more about
what are the sort of exciting
pathways for the future in
biomedical engineering and
cancer treatment.
Great, so I'll see you on
Thursday.